[Music]
[Music]
everybody welcome back to come on a
beach episode 32 today I'm here with
Rudy when Camille I really high self
hiding I am I'm doing fine actually how
are you oh well I'm a little bit
stressed out cuz I'm in Berlin at the
moment sitting in my hotel room and just
came back from uni 10 hours of uni today
oh yeah right right I'm just confident
in my in my own bedroom and everything
is kind of chill so I suppose we're in
very kind of different locations in that
sense yeah so at least my hotel room
this time is really good it's really
good you're cooking a different hotel
every time yeah because of prizes and
stuff all right
I like it good and before we go on
actually I do when I quickly say ladies
I know it isn't here I'm actually gonna
look for her text basically she promised
her boyfriend that she and him would
have a special night or something
tonight so I'm not sure what they're up
to but in any case other issues in life
and obviously maintaining a relationship
is much more important than planet
poster so I said that serious sorry if I
sounded very sarcastic on that line I
wasn't I was just self-deprecating humor
and in any case I'm now a laughing word
but I shouldn't go into it fun you sure
yeah yeah I know it's fine it's fine
it's it's sad that she's here but it's
really it's really important to keep
like your real life relationships
working from oh yeah
and not not played too much planet
coaster and you know have other social
activities completely fall behind hmm in
any case by today I'm working in the
area around the mind train since there
wasn't really anything around here the
main goal that I set off for this
episode by the way was to go around the
empty areas of the park and fill in the
areas that were still empty in an
attempt to sort of get to a more
finished prana Beach and I sort of let
myself down here because I am I only got
to one of these areas and I didn't even
have time to go to the rest so our only
be sticking in this area but that said I
will be adding a lot of detail to this
area and the first thing that I wanted
to go for is a small drink shop it's not
really a restaurant or anything it's
really just a store that's disguised as
a way to make this feel more like a town
and it's a little pitch shot juice I
think that's what it's called
stall with a small building around it I
totally laughs that building actually
it's it's it's simple yet really cool I
also love how the little pillars on the
left-hand side with those bells hanging
down and the lamps that kind of gives it
a little bit of a different touch like
it's not a straight mm-hmm by those and
it also has kind of and I I do just take
it as really serious notes to it it has
a little bit of African style to it
which is just a little bit as a touch to
it but I think it fits really well into
because then with a set roof and with
those wooden stuff we get bit back into
the area where we are and those were
looking really nice oh thank you I was
actually yeah that was one of my main
worries while I was building this I was
really just randomly plopping this stuff
together usually that's not an approach
that I'm a fan of I like to at least
blend my stuff ahead in my mind a little
bit more but in this case I was just
starting off with something and randomly
any ideas
until other so important I was really
afraid that I was going to look to
African and it definitely kind of does
in a sense but hopefully the context of
the Polynesian atmosphere around here
will bring that back into the theme a
little bit more and also there is
actually going to be another building in
this build which has completely
different style of architecture but
that's not really something I should go
into right now I feel like sure yeah
it's really cool-looking and I think the
thing about just going in and then
plopping down doesn't work for quality
quite good because I think which is only
one hand side we talked about this in
the last episode might be also a bad
reason but it's also a good thing we are
really used to this kind of architecture
right now because we used it so often
and so I think you just nail it
because you also are used to you know
get it together like we've done it for
the whole time in quality Beach so
mm-hmm yeah it is like a physical thing
it is definitely a challenge to come up
with new ways to use the items in ways
that look very different from what we've
been doing and I think we've also
mentioned in fact that it's becoming
harder and harder to come up with new
stuff as a reason to end quality it's
pretty soon but overall yeah I'm quite
glad with how it turned out even if it
had some slightly different influences
all around the place actually found some
sort of inspiration again in lone Wolf's
builds on shyguys world which are just
amazing because they use this word work
a lot place all kinds of clutter around
and even though they might not be as
interesting architectural II because
they're usually quite simple and
down-to-earth I think that just makes it
work all the better for theme parks
because it's something that you'd be
more able to afford in a theme park not
every building is a huge Disney console
or some big weenie if you will but a lot
of buildings are especially in theme
parks not really that interesting
architectural early and just around for
there one use of being a shop and just
inviting is just being part of the scene
and I guess that's that's really the
role of this building here yeah it is
hey I just know that texture but like
this great texture them seem to be very
but yeah just back to a point I'm yeah
totally with you and also I know his
buildings as well I just recently
stepped back into shy gasps well a
little bit I even though I didn't add
anything but I just wanted to take a
little bit of time and go through it
because I haven't been there for months
but actually I think there was also
somebody mentioning it some buildings
and in fact are so important you they
are there but when they are gone you
would definitely notice that they're
missing and I guess it's kind of
building like that you know it's there
because it's a shop and you need it but
it would be a way it would be missing
because it's like kind of an empty space
but if it would be too fancy it might be
displaced right I think that's also a
fairly interesting thing to to take into
account when building a theme park that
you can't always go for like just fancy
buildings yeah it's very impossible
because make the fancy buildings fancy
then when everything else is senti as
well
I think somebody taught me a long time
ago that you can't see the detail if
there are no places without detail and
you don't really notice how amazing some
buildings are if the rest of the
buildings aren't very much toned down to
bring the attention to the buildings
that you're supposed to bring your
attention to so yeah is that yeah very
much an important point there yeah
definitely I mean it's it's just like in
life right if you you wouldn't have any
bad experiences you wouldn't even know
what our good experiences like right
we're totally getting Buddhism to
neutral oh yeah okay let's get to
feedbacks again yeah that's that's funny
yeah yeah anyway then there was a bit
about the concrete texture that I ripped
from you because that concrete takes you
so damn good it just it just fits
perfectly and it also kind of made me
realize how well the textures do work
for path textures because you don't
really need the light to interact in any
special ways with part-time students you
don't really write and need super
reflective textures or very toned
Texters I think it works just right
compared to the in-game textures so yes
I ordered Acula so yeah we have this
this bit of stone path to fill in the
plaza in the middle over here and I just
wanted to bring some tables and stuff
into the area so there's just a tiny
space where you can take your dreams
from the Big Shot store whatever it's
called I think I call it entropic which
is a terrible name I should I should
replace that maybe with some better name
something also the my trains still need
to name but yeah it's just a little
place where you can sit down
I noticed especially when I went to
wallaby recently that places to sit down
is something that you don't really think
about in a theme park but it's something
you really need a lot of mm-hmm
y-yeah yep definitely I mean oh you're
doing a new powerful that's cool this is
not mine actually this is the idea to
use these cloths was taken from CTR
Sindh
you might know him as Bryan over at cha
guys world so total props to him for
coming up with this idea because they
look amazing I don't know I mean it said
it so coolly I mean you you just know
like nearly everybody is just to craft
ideas from what school I mean it's good
to mention them but I would forget about
some names actually but I'm bad at names
generally so oh I am horrible at names
as well it's just that maybe I've been
in these corners for a little bit too
long something like that he actually did
appear on that on broke coaster as well
which is an amazing episode maybe I
should stop looking bro coaster but only
read somewhere in the description if I
don't forget quale Beach featuring
comments about Pro coaster just just
watch the complete series and and take a
piña colada every time somebody here and
pro coaster okay I don't want to be no
no don't put this guy's because maybe we
get problems afterwards looks kind of
legal issues because people thinking
themselves yeah I'm not sure if those
exist even I'm not sure if you can get
into legal issues because of forcing
people to do drinking games that are
actually a terrible idea maybe that's
maybe that's something to do research on
surely somewhere in the deep dark corner
of the internet somebody's somebody to
suss this out in any case back to the
park I wanted to get to a few of the
parts that you were working on here
since they didn't have any borders I
think I was the person who removed the
borders though so my bad I guess but I
at least wanted to fill in this area
with a bit of simple detailing to bring
all the different parts together that's
pretty cool yeah actually I just have to
jump into this boy because it was quite
a little discussion last time in the
comments like me leaving a lot of gaps
to you guys which which kind of exploded
to into a topic which isn't that big for
us I guess the truth that I left some
some rooms for you guys but the last
episode I took myself into building also
some you know for example the toilet
over here and stuff like that and also I
just remembered recently that I did the
temple to fill the area between the boom
run coaster and the what the the river
rapids right using is one way I built
the temple in and I think I also love
those episodes especially where you are
going to spend your eye on paths and
foliage because I think you are really
like the king of foliage and and paths
interaction with all this kind of stuff
and I'm not sure if I would like to call
myself that but it's something I'll
refer to later on in this episode for
sure like let's call it you're the king
out of our threes in terms of that maybe
if that makes you feel better a little
bit I'll go back on it I never mind I
just wanted to mention that because it
sounded a little bit harsh and our
comments but even though it I think it's
a fine topic for us right right I
definitely agree I think what really
sparked it that I was
moaning in the last episode about Rudy
always and in big projects and having to
fill up the gaps between those big
projects it's more or less just the way
that we are doing koala [ __ ] and I was
just mocking that just for fun and we're
both on the same line in terms of that
because like you said I do think my best
role is just to fill in the different
areas and sort of bring areas together
for only gaps here in there add some
foliage and part work here in there and
Rudy's best serve to actually bring in
the new projects because he just you
just bring the the best creative ideas
and every time you have an episode
there's something really new and
exciting happening which i and lady can
just you know go further with like last
episode you you built the golf cars got
the new textures in some backstage
elements that we didn't have before and
it's just all kinds of stuff that we can
build further from so really it's not
really something that I'm mad about at
all in fact it's just a way that Coney
Beach works and it's the way that I
think we're all using what we're best at
in you know compared to each other like
yeah totally agree on that I think
that's kind of cool thing to mention as
well because that's basically how
collaborations in general should work
like it wouldn't be I mean it could be
fun if you're all exactly the same kind
of type but I don't know if that would
take you any further then mm-hmm because
if you it's like in a good team you
always need different different persons
with with different skills oh yeah
definitely so I think that's also a fun
part and you know I'm also like I'm
really I can I really can laugh about
myself I'm totally into this like you
know I'm always going into our chats and
just you know bringing especially you to
get a little bit of a heart attack by
just mentioning that I might bring a new
coaster in the next even though I'm not
but right yeah that's true I actually
just kind of realized that the way this
those kind of work is that usually you
kind of bring in in the new big projects
and stuff I fill in a lot of gaps and if
it weren't for Lady then this part
would not be fit for families whatsoever
because she's a kid bringing more of the
family entertainment that we always
forget about like flat ride skinning and
doing mini-golf that sort of stuff so
yeah it's it's definitely bringing in no
comparative comparatively what certain
people are best at that's what a
collaboration should all be about okay
now I'm into what you meant by wienie
yeah this is to just completely God holy
[ __ ] that's the wienie that I forgot to
record whilst over over an hour of
recording there because I completely
forgot to hit the record button that was
kind of a shame like you got really
quick yeah yeah I actually got quicker
building for once because I should
probably mention I was an extreme
slowpoke while I'm doing this episode
load it in Devon Laurie
the lady was telling me four days to
finish off that episode and Central Park
filed her and damn I was slacking on
this things just kept take Kemp taking
me longer than I expected but yeah but
back to the temple I suppose it's a
building that's inspired by Balinese
temples that you'll see in Indonesia
you've probably seen some pictures of it
right there those big sort of straw
temples with all of these different
floors and they're super tall and
actually a little bit thinner than then
you usually would expect oh yeah yeah
like they're like narrow sprites almost
yeah that's really cool I mean I do like
it exit eight it's just remember I just
remembered I just forgot about what
never mind it just shows me again how
much influences from different
architectures are in this kind of areas
all around like we were talking about
the Spanish oh sorry not Spanish let the
African inspired building beforehand and
now this could also be considered to be
a little bit more asian-inspired you
know and it's really cool to see
actually going more and more deep into
it that kind of brings out how many
different styles or architecture go into
it but in in general the whole picture
it kind of definitely makes sense as
kind of the pulling
Asian architecture pretty cool yeah and
I would say actually that the Polynesian
style of architecture that we are going
for is already kind of a mismatch
it's a mishmash isn't it it's already
finished Matt I guess a mismatch is a
mishmash that doesn't really work out it
so it submit so sorry I'll see myself
out in any case it's a bit of a mishmash
because it's not an architectural style
that really exists in real life it's
something that you'll find in Disney's
Polynesian village it's very Disney in
general it's something none you'll find
in TV shows movies that kind of stuff
but there is no singular Polynesian
style it's like saying there's European
architecture it's it is already kind of
a weird mix of different things and it's
eclectic in that sense
so I guess bringing in different
influences like that into into the theme
like this it's quite fine and to be
honest there are some theme parks in
real life which claim to have Asian
sections and they're building them to
look nothing like Asian architecture
though comparatively speaking I suppose
quality [ __ ] is doing all right from
that--from yeah definitely is definitely
I mean I like the way how it turned out
in general like the whole picture of the
park is just incredibly well and then I
also think that it doesn't matter if
that's a real kind of style of
architecture or if it would be like
inspired by a theme park kind of
architecture I mean like theme parks in
general can be considered as an example
for a special kind of architecture
mm-hmm bring in a totally new concept in
terms of of a park layout and offer like
a really separated world in that kind of
sense because they have like kind of all
elements for example the city would have
so you know there is kind of the city
center that was kind of the you know
service area and stuff like that you
know what I'm trying to get it so it is
kind of a real term to be considered
that it was theme park
brings out a new kind of architecture
yeah I'm not sure if I'm exactly on the
same point I definitely agree that that
theme-park architecture is completely
different from regular architecture but
personally I feel like it's more of a
it's more of a like buildings in theme
parks aren't standing on themselves as
much as buildings in real life art
because you're designing everything
along with the landscape and along with
the buildings around it and along with
all kinds of thinkers that you don't
really have in a regular city so it's
more like oh yeah the buildings are just
a part of the scenery in a deficit
social I just wanted to try to to point
out that the theme park as kind of
environment is all they're able to bring
out new kind of architecture styles
because of their challenges so that is
very well we go for it just exists
because it works good for a theme park
which is definitely true there actually
some interesting things one of the most
interesting things about architecture
and theme points is that you don't
really have to care about people being
inside them - yeah definitely that's
that's probably the one single most
important thing like if you look at the
temple for instance that could not be a
real Balinese temple because you simply
would not be able to get inside of it
yep totally
and also not get to the top of it oh
yeah it was spring anything yeah
especially not that a that forced
perspective I suppose which you might
know from Disney's main streets for
instance yeah use force perspective on
each floor so every consecutive floor on
Main Street buildings in Disney is
slightly smaller than the one before
it's to the point where the top floor of
the Disney building would be way too
small for a regular person to sit in oh
yeah and I've got a feeling that if you
might look into the comments that a guy
called the elf sandal will definitely
have some added information for you guys
out there so make sure to work the
comment section what with the idea of
faendal has to say about this operation
it's a real G point I've actually I've
gotten some comments about that from
King rct3 quite a few times already as
well
so maybe we'll see some some teaming up
in the comment section happening about
his new trivia yeah it's pretty cool I
also got a little bit more into it and
also watched all these kind of
documentaries about the first Disney
Park in California what they also used
the building for later on like having
control rooms in there and you know
later on they also faced the fact that
the upper floor wasn't able to be used
as a control room because it was too
small and then they had kind of cooling
systems in there and stuff like that so
it's pretty cool how they just used this
kind of stuff right yet they are really
interesting parks and they're also some
of the first theme parks so I like
personally I feel that makes those
podcasts and documentaries and all kinds
of videos about Disney even more
interesting because it's it's sort of
seeing the theme park industry grow
surely there are more themed points that
used for in that use force perspective
in a similar vein but Disney was the
park to sort of establish and kick-start
at all so they were trying to find their
feet and that's why I think yeah
especially those documentaries are
interesting because they make mistakes
and it shows even more how brilliant
that kind of stuff was like the Fotolia
ride
I remember in Disney you know those car
rides where you're on the side f nida
grill the first one didn't have that
guided reel so people were just crashing
into each other and it was mayhem so
Disney kind of looked and learned from
that you actually put those reels on the
right it's that kind of stuff which just
makes you think outside the box a little
bit more and kind of appreciate that you
know they had to start from nowhere with
coming up with this kind of stuff
yeah and sylph by the way at the moment
you're kind of destroying off for him
rate even more aren't you so do it with
the foliage it wasn't too bad actually
it's not like yeah oh by the way it is
actually then then my regular sort of
small section of foliage because there's
they're just trees no bushes or anything
did you have kind of an improvement from
the latest update by the way about the
they claim especially in park with a lot
of pieces it should be a little better
why I'm
sure I had a little I had a little bit
of a problem so I couldn't even test it
that good so I need to check it next
time but right yeah I yeah right oh you
did yeah I did some lighting stuff as
well which is pretty fun but yeah I
tried it but um
I tried to see if the framerate was
better but when I first open the game it
was a non porous mode I wasn't even
realizing that and it was in less than
11 frames per second which was kind of
horrible and I'm at about 20 frames per
second post which I think isn't that
much better than what it used to be but
I'm not entirely sure on that so I'll
really have to check that I mean but
maybe quality isn't the best example - I
mean - no that's a recovery sir this is
ridiculous in terms of piece count and I
have to say that I think in comparison
to what we've experienced especially in
alpha and later on at the beginning of
of the fully leased game as well you
wouldn't be able to run this park and
quite yet after a few updates we are
still able to run this park I mean
without guests but for me at least I I
mostly used my kicks without guests even
yeah lady can still run it fine but yeah
that's that's totally true
so think that's a good point I think the
thing that makes it so that the last
update isn't helping as much though as
some of the other performance updates is
from what I remember and correct me if
I'm wrong but from what I remember and
they say was that he worked on the
building pieces so building pieces and
it should be less heavy as soon as you
have many open in the park but since our
lag is probably stemming mostly from
trees and particle effects that sort of
stuff I think that's not included in
making the performance better in the
latest update I'm not entirely sure
anymore how it works
but it was something like that yeah
that's totally fair yeah totally
so yeah for now we are guided through
yeah we are right so yeah we're doing
with the time lapses so I guess we're
done with this this episode I would
actually love to end it with
North shoutouts I'm not even sure if I
shouted this out yet so I'm just giving
this again in quanta [ __ ] I know I
think I did it and latest grapefruit but
big shout out to bro basics which is
yeah I'm doing this again which is the
sort of tutorial series from bro coaster
their latest video bro basics number two
about nature was a really great episode
we've both watched it and it's
definitely something that's been going
into my mind much more consciously
recently it's a great episode about
doing foliage and it's something that's
really influencing my foliage and what
you said about me being the foliage King
is something that I definitely don't
want to exempt because I have to pass it
over to mr. n7 from cold coaster because
if there's anybody education about
gardening and foliage it's him and
totally true yeah I kind of forgot for a
second about him but yeah that's
basically the only reason why I already
knew him before that I mean like he was
really one of the only ones I remember
from my days back at rollercoaster
tycoon 3 oh yeah yeah he made it all
custom signal in that game as well yeah
basically that's also why and but we
can't end it right here so if we have
forgotten to say something I guess yeah
about a little bit of a contest this is
a very good point so who's going to
start this we didn't exactly prepare
this no but I think you are already
mentioning that for example there is
something missing we don't have a name
for the mind train coaster and stuff
like that but even more important we
don't have a logo for the park no I
think there's there's something coming
up to fix that issue isn't it yeah you
wanna maybe explain people what this is
good I'll try my best anyway okay no our
idea is as follows we're going to do a
contest and this time it's not a contest
inside
planet coaster itself not a contest to
design anything in planet coaster but a
contest to design a logo for quality
and we're going to announce the top ten
will also make a video of it and for the
winner of this contest we actually have
a lot of amazing stuff from which are
able to actually support us on this
which is amazing and now a little bit of
the data stuff guys
I mean the most important thing the
stuff you can get is actually a goodie
bag assigned Planko Edition including
the DLCs and as well as an expo ticket
for the frontier Expo so if you can make
a Nicola Silla have the frontier Expo is
a big event taking place the 7th of
October this year in London and there
will be amazing stuff going on like
everything about planned coaster also
easy dangerous and yeah kind of
everything
frontier does as well as some other cool
stuff going on and live streams and you
can meet a lot of great people being
there and yeah also meet a lot of
persons and well-known mates from
frontier themselves so actually pretty
cool if you can make it there
yeah if not there's still the goodie bag
the sign tanker edition and the DLCs
yeah all you have to do is to send in
your layout and it's important maybe to
mention that you consider having it a
PNG file because we will have to use it
for a few different occasions and so we
might need a dlc file a PNG file sorry
until the 12th of August which is in one
week's time a little bit less than one
week's time right no it's exactly in one
week yeah no that's cool it's six days
from when I'm uploading this video
though oh that's right so that yeah
we're okay that's fine
so in six days and the winner will be
announced the 23rd of August been right
are you actually you were way better
than that
when I was so thanks man those items I
just had a nice message in front of me
oh you did yeah oh yeah I said you think
that you actually prepared that yeah I
think I did it while recording I just
you know took my phone and yeah I was
looking at it but yeah guys I think
that's a pretty cool thing to do I would
love to do it
but I can take yeah unfortunately
although the expo is going to be amazing
I'm not sure if I'm going to be there
but it's also going to have a huge
planet Costa Community mean ups so like
like really said there will be a lot of
planet coaster related people including
correct me if I'm mistaken
Rudy himself and lady oh that's right
yeah yeah today I got actually today I
got the confirmation from uni that I can
go so that's cool oh and I just have to
sort out all the stuff which was you
know flights and stuff like that but
that will somehow work yeah yeah I
should say I'm still waiting on that
confirmation myself so I'm not sure I'll
be able to go but I definitely hope so
and if there's any opportunity for me to
just screw university over and go there
anyway I would definitely love to take
it so oh yeah I add up I'd also love to
do again stuff with you two together
like meeting up again ah again like Oh
even more than one year we go from games
come playing with pretty cool yeah and I
think that's all you have to say about
the contest I know it's on very short
notice but it's also in parts because
koala peach ending is on very short
notice we're not going to review
anything else about this quite yet but
we do have lots of video works in our
plans and a bit of a schedule for it so
there's going to be lots of content
popping up about it and hence also why
this logo is very strictly fitting in
that schedule with content yeah
definitely and the big shout out also to
lady again because she's always trying
to get both of us into picture of
schedule which is not lonely which is we
love good actually yeah yeah it's really
good pictures it's deliberate heart with
the two of us we're really sizable more
chaotic than this video my
make it didn't actually scrap that this
video is already quite chaotic yeah
alright I think that's really it yeah
that's it
I'm not sure how I'm going to feel all
this time maybe I'll get a ton of
footage in or something but in any case
so my word to sort of melted together in
that sentence but in any case that's it
for qwali beach episode 32 rudy thank
you so much for being here again yeah oh
I appreciate it thank you you're welcome
of course it's always great to have you
in here and to you the viewers I would
like to say thank you for watching
thanks for spitting in this weird
episode that got very currently put
together and hopefully you'll be able to
make some awesome logos good luck with
the contest and yeah that's basically
all that's to say good bye guys and hope
to see you guys in the next episode of
quanta [ __ ] bye bye